نتواجد اليوم هنا في المواصلات الخاصه
بمدينه نيالا بولايه شرق دارفور غربي
السودان بعد انقطاع اكثر من 36 مدينه
باقليم دارفور عن الاتصالات اصبح لا سبيل
للمواطنين في الحصول على الاخبار سوى
الوصول الى هذه المواقف والاسواق بغرض
تتبع ما يدور في بعض الولايات فشبكات
الاتصالات في غرب دارفور وفي وسط دارفور
منقطعه تماما وهنالك ايضا عدد من محليات
اقليم دارفور لا توجد بها اتصالات والله
اتصال ماهر من عيد رمضان ولهذا الان الشبه
الرابعه
ما قادرين نتواصل معها نحن جايين من النيل
الازرق
فقلنا نمشي نشيف الحاصل شنو
كل المناطق لحد الجنينه
قاضي
كل المناطق
ما في اتصالات بعد
كبير في
شكل عائق
في النسبه للصحفيين والذين يعملون في
المواقع ووكالات الانباء المختلفه هنا
باغليم دارفور حيث يمثل السوق هو المكان
الوحيد للحصول على هذه الاخبار التي قد
تاتي قديمه ويمر عليها اكثر من يوم بسبب
انقطاع الاتصالات وعدم الحصول على تغطيه
كافيه في عدد من المناطق الساخنه باقليم
دارفور والتي دارت فيها معارك وداري فيها
قتال الايام الماضيه
لو حتى الان يعني بتجيني خطابات من
الولايات مختلفه رغم ان الشبكه توقفت
والتواصل
يعني وقعدت بتجينا خطابات ورسائل في مختلف
الولايات حتى الان اصحابهم قادرين يوصلوا
عليها ورغم انه الشبكه يعني مين الشبكه ما
وقفت لحد الليله الناس بقت ترجع لموضوع
الخطابات الزمان
تقول بعض شركات الاتصالات العامله هنا في
اقليم دارفور ان ابرز ما يواجهها من
تحديات هو التحدي الامني بنسبه للعاملين
في هذه الشركات كما ان عمليه الحصول على
الوقود الذي ياتي من الخرطوم يمثل تحدي
كبير لعمل هذه الشركات باقليمي دارفور
صالح ابو علامه لقناته العربيه والحدث
اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات